traitors
we are here because they are violating the
right of our president because
Pedro Castillo is still our
president he
has kidnapped our president and he is
here to the people throughout the 17 months
that I have been in office a certain sector of the
parliament
of the vacancy the plenary session of the Congress of
this way approves the vacancy of the
the resolution declaring
the vacancy of the presidency of the
republic has been approved it should
be noted that while at liberty
Mr. Pedro Castillo terrones could
communicate
with these people so that they
hide and or destroy elements of
conviction
that prevent  finding out the truth